welcome the legume ears Vita was part of
the invitation and and you also saw it
and I saw some of you picked it up at
the registration so I will not go
through it he's very well-known let me
mention only that he's deputy leader of
the party of Russian freedom better
known as by the Russian acronym of para
nós he's the resident coordinator of
Mikhail Khodorkovsky's open Russia I say
resident because Lattimer actually moved
he lives in in Russia now or rather he's
recuperating and then he will move there
and we'll get to that in a moment
he's also a Cambridge trained historian
an author of several monographs one of
which I hope to be able to discuss here
and he is of course a prolific and most
enjoyable and insightful commentator on
Russian domestic and foreign policies
with publications and all leading
Western and Russian media so thank you
very much Volodya for coming over we're
honored to have you
thank you very much Leon and thank you
to the American Enterprise Institute for
organizing and hosting our meeting today
Paula yeah we were all very saddened and
disturbed by the news about your
mysterious near fatal illness in the
last week of May then you were in a coma
for quite a while so what happened
exactly
well before I ask you a question I just
want to say that today is October the
9th and today is the birthday of Boris
Nemtsov he would have been 56 and it's
the first birthday without him and there
is there's a Russian saying as you know
news emini working you were right there
are no irreplaceable people but that
saying is not true because Boris was
irreplaceable as a political leader as a
human being and as a friend and he
inspired so many people with his courage
his vision and his commitment to always
do the right thing regardless of the
price and in the end he paid the
ultimate price in his struggle for a
free and democratic
and we shall never forget and we don't
have to carry on the work without him
and we will carry on but it will be so
much more difficult now to your question
as you said it was the last week of May
May 26 to be precise I've just come back
from one of my many trips around Russian
regions I was at a meeting in Moscow and
I was suddenly taken ill with an acute
intoxication of unidentified origins I
went to Tel coma all my major organs
started failing just shutting down one
after another the heart the lungs the
kidneys all that and the in fact doctors
told my wife that I had a 5% chance of
making it out of life so I'm very
grateful to be here today and I'm very
grateful for the for the concern and the
support and the prayers of so many
people in Russia in this country and
elsewhere so I just want to take this
opportunity to thank everybody it really
means a great deal and we still do not
know the cause the the poison the toxin
that caused the poisoning was not
identified the tests are inconclusive so
I guess we'll never know the exact
poison but of course to stay the obvious
certainly this was not an accident this
was not natural and this this was
somehow connected with my public
activities inside Russia and I should
add of course that in addition to being
the Lea deputy leader of Karnas you're
also the resident coordinator of Mikhail
Khodorkovsky's open Russia right the
open Russia movement exactly well
Volodya as I mentioned among many hats
that you wear perhaps the largest is
well one of the largest is that of a
Russia expert so let me start with one
issue that this town is mostly concerned
about these days Syria why do you think
why do you think Putin decided to go
there and and what is his objective or
objectives well I think as was as with
all foreign policy adventures of the
current regime the origins are domestic
and everything this Kremlin has been
doing in the last several years
especially since 2011 2012 when we saw
the biggest pro-democracy protests
on the streets of Moscow during the
whole time of Putin's rule especially
since then everything they've been doing
was dedicated to one she called the
preservation of their power thank you so
much and that's why I think for example
that Putin's aggression against Ukraine
was not primarily about geopolitics or
spheres of influence what he disliked
the most was the precedent of a corrupt
authoritarian ruler fleeing as popular
protests were breaking out in the
capital city he really didn't enjoy
those pictures of mr. Yanukovych
boarding the helicopter and what he was
afraid the most and I think rightly is
that a successful democratic Ukraine
would be a contagious bad in his view
example for Russian society and I think
he was right in that and that's why he
had to do everything he could to try to
prevent the success and so with this
latest adventure in Syria I think the
regime needed frankly new ammunition for
his propaganda machine which is the main
essential pillar support pillar for the
Putin regime and now Ukraine's become a
quagmire the novorossiya project has
clearly failed the economies in the free
fall they need something you know to oil
the propaganda machine and they chose
this and now if you look at the russian
state TV news Ukraine's almost
completely gone it's all about serious
serious serious uper power of flying
across the other side of the world doing
you know what we want without asking
anybody and and so on and so forth of
course an added bonus to this for mr.
Putin is to help a fellow dictator stay
in power as we know the the informal
international club of dictators is a
loyal one and and mr. Putin does not
like to see fellow despots lose their
position he seen too many in recent
years from you know from Qaddafi to
Yanukovych and so we are seeing now that
the main targets for Russian airstrikes
are not in fact Isis areas but the the
anti-assad opposition we've all seen the
maps you know Homs and so forth which is
not an Isis area but I think there is a
potentially very big program for the
Kremlin
the problem being that Syria could
possibly become for Putin
what Afghanistan became for the late
Soviet regime you know and draining an
unpopular foreign military adventure
that helped hastened the system's demise
in the end and there are already
warnings being founded to this effect
and in fact there is a new poll by the
Levada Center yesterday which show that
despite all the barrage of the bravado
and the propaganda that we see today
almost half of Russians half almost half
of respondents are afraid already today
that Syria could become or Afghanistan
became for the late Soviet Union so I
think you know for all for all the hype
that's being put up today I think that
that's a potentially big problem for the
regime below the presidential primaries
are starting in this country unite
talked about better and unlike Russians
we don't know who the next president
will be
so with that uncertainty comes comes
there are some intellectual work what
would be your advice to the presidential
hopefuls of both parties let me narrow
this a bit
what would you say be three four or five
things they must keep in mind as they
shape and project the Russia portion of
their foreign policy message well I
think I think they're all informed and
intelligent people so I wouldn't presume
to tell them something they don't know
but I wouldn't presume yeah but I would
say this I think many political leaders
in the West including in this country
too many fall into one of the two
extremes when it comes to the approach
to the current Kremlin regime either
they want to make friends with it or the
other opposite is they blame the entire
Russian nation for the actions of this
unelected authoritarian system and I
think it's the most important thing for
policy makers of presidential candidates
is to is to recognize the situation as
it is and the fact is that Russia today
is ruled by an unaccountable unelected
dictatorial regime
and if history teaches us anything it's
that making friends with such regimes
and closing eyes on their abuses is not
a sound long-term strategy and
unfortunately we've seen
administration's of both parties in this
town try to do this you know remember
President Bush famously looking into
Putin's eyes and seeing his soul
remember the reset policy of the current
President Barack Obama so I think if if
if principles on which this nation was
founded still means something for
political leaders it's those values that
should inform the attitude towards the
regime that routinely abuses the rights
of its own citizens and now also the
borders and sovereignty of other nations
and short term deals or such regimes of
the expense of fundamental values I
don't think are the answer I think the
answer ultimately lies in democracy and
rule of law in Russia itself and the
fact is that Russia deserves better than
what we have today and the fact is that
Russia is not destined to remain under
the system forever
and I think it's very important for
policy makers to have this understanding
and to recognize the system above all
when they shave the policy thank you
very much now let me broaden this issue
a little bit no matter no matter who the
next president will be one thing I think
we can be sure of and you alluded to it
like all US presidents from both parties
pretty much since the establishment of
the diplomatic relations between the
United States and Soviet Union and in in
1933 she or he would wish two things for
Russia to be prosperous and to be free
what can the United States do to further
the emergence of such a Russia well I
think first of all I'd like to say that
it's our job to bring Democratic changes
to our country no one else's and I don't
think it can be done from outside I
don't think it should be done from the
outside it's it's for us to do but if
the US wants to show solidarity with
those people in Russia who want a future
based on democracy and rule of law
I think the main thing to do is to stand
by and abide by its own fundamental
principles to speak openly and frankly
about the abuses of the Kremlin regime
not to close their eyes on it not to
pretend that the corrupt dictator in the
Kremlin is a-- isn't is a partner at the
same time differentiate and emphasized
this differentiation between the kremlin
regime and russia and maintain lines of
communication was with civil society in
russia with democratic movement in
russia and it very importantly keep out
the prospect of a future democratic
Russia being an equal partner on the
world stage that's a very important
prospect to happen to to Parral but I
think most importantly is practice the
principles you preach frankly and there
is I'll give one example there is a law
on the books in the United States the
Magnitsky Act which was passed nearly
three years ago passed with unseen or
rarely seen bipartisan majorities in
both houses of Congress signed by
President Obama in December 2012 I think
one of the most principled and honorable
pieces of legislation ever passed in any
foreign Parliament it's as you know of
course it's designed to end the impunity
for those who continue to abuse the
rights and freedoms of Russian citizens
and steal the money of Russian taxpayers
by denying them the privilege of
traveling to and owing assets in this
country a privilege I should add they so
greatly enjoy for all the many
similarities we can discuss with a
Soviet regime there is one major
difference with this one you know
Brezhnev Sullivan and drop off did not
buy yachts hold bank accounts or send
their kids to study in the Democratic
West this bunch do and so I think ending
this double standard is a very important
way for the u.s. to show solidarity with
those in Russia who struggle for a
democratic future frankly almost three
years after this law has been passed and
signed implementation remains pretty
timid and so far we've seen on your
low-level abuses targeted so I think
it's important for the u.s. to step up
and be more bold and more forthcoming
and target some more prominent and
influential people and one idea that a
former prime minister Conniff and I
suggested earlier this year we came
to this town and met with congressional
leaders was to include the officials
from the state propaganda machine for
the public incitement against the late
Boris Nemtsov before his 4:00 in the
month leading up to his murder there you
know the incitement that created this
atmosphere that made it possible to
murder the leader of the Opposition 200
yards away from the Kremlin and I should
add that this law and these personal
targeted sanctions on abusers and
corrupt officials are very popular with
the Russian people that despite all of
its propaganda possibilities the regime
has failed to present this the Magnitsky
process as quote sanctions against
Russia people understand that you know
targeting those who abused their rights
and steal their money it's not sanctions
against Russia that's a pro-russian
measure and so even despite the
situation today these measures are very
popular with what the citizens of Russia
and I think would be really important if
if the US and hopefully also the
European Union afterwards would follow
up and be more bold in its
implementation well let's talk a little
bit about a subject you know so well
intimately I would say the domestic
politics and the policies of the regime
local elections were held last month
your party Parnas was the only one the
only opposition party and I'm not
counting the ones in the in the rubber
stamp it was the only party that was
allowed to participate but then only
ultimately in one region of Russia
Castorama
one of Russia's 85 regions so on the one
hand I guess congratulations are in
order on the other hand given that that
you know it was only in one region and
that your candidate got less than 2% of
the vote that seems like another sign of
the consolidation of the Putin
dictatorship now at the same time though
your recent interview with Moskovsky
Komsomolets was very interesting because
among other things you said that these
restrictions are the regime of I'm sorry
the evidence of regimes weakness and and
fear could you explain to us what what
happen
exactly and why do you think the regime
is is is in that position sure thanks
for the question and I think it's
important to always remember as you
rightly pointed out that in the vast
majority of cases Russian citizens did
not get a real choice at the ballot box
did not get a real alternative in the
rare cases when they do the Opposition
often scores very significant results
such as when Alexei Navalny got nearly
30 percent of the vote in Moscow two
years ago or when Boris Nemtsov was
elected as the head of the para nós
ticket in Yaroslavl also two years ago
but in the in most cases Russian voters
are stuck with the pre-selected pool of
pro-kremlin parties a robust umpire
party says he called them and then these
recent local and municipal elections
that were held in September our party
Parnassus was prevented from running in
another severe scree Jian in the Kaluga
region a Magadan region for the city do
my Nizhny Novgorod so this is the usual
pattern of behavior for this regime they
bar genuine opposition from the ballot
the harass independent election monitors
they ban or disperse opposition rallies
and generally try to stifle and prevent
and block any manifestation of
independent Civic activity anything that
doesn't you know conform to their goals
for example as you mentioned I'm the
coordinator of the open Russia movement
at one of my main tasks is to organize
public events around Russia much much as
this one you know discussions seminars
lectures were trying to recreate the
space for public discussion for free and
unfettered public discussion has been so
limited by this regime and almost every
time that we hold such events you know
we get police seizing the the building
we have you know the being announced
that the building is bombed the
electricity goes out all the rest of
every time they try to do something to
prevent you know our events from
happening every time they try to do
something to stop us from going ahead
and and in this election customer that
you mentioned open Russia had a big
pretty big vote monitoring operation we
sent a vote monitoring mission to
customize that this was a pilot project
for us with Nina
hopefully expand on this for next year's
State Duma election and do a nationwide
but this was this was a kind of the
pilot version a non-voting day itself
we had an armed police court block
headquarters you know ostensibly they
were looking for a dead body inside our
vote monitoring mission of course they
didn't find a dead body but what they
did do was detaining questioned our
coordinators our monitors and basically
sabotage the mission now in my mind this
is not the behavior of a strong popular
and self-confident government this is
the behavior of people who are afraid of
every challenge or any challenge to
their position and I think frankly you
know from especially given the
historical lessons I think they have
every right to be afraid but that's what
yeah that's not a behavior of a strong
partner and self-confident government
you do not fear your opponents if you
are speaking of historical lessons
change your head to that away Cambridge
trained historian let me ask you
something that that has been on my mind
for quite a while there is a there's a
widely shared opinion hysteria type
basically yeah that Russians long for a
strong arm that their backs are aching
for a whip and with Putin's popularity
ratings such as they are and I want you
to address that issue as well this
cliche is back and forth and yet when
you look at at the history in those rare
instances when the Russian people were
given and more or less free choice and
more or less imperfect choice however
imperfect and more or less informed
choice the story is quite different and
I would like to bring up this excellent
book of yours that I always consult
reformulate evaluate say reforms or the
revolution by Vladimir it's about the
elections to the first Russian Duma the
first Russian more or less freely
elected parliament in 1906 and as you
tracked it with all kinds of fascinating
details of course the plurality of
Deputies the party would most vote
pitties in the Duma was the openly
liberal pro-western party of
constitutional democrats cajeta
and then of course we've seen this again
and again over eight decades passed
before the Russians could vote again
again more or less freely and we saw the
results in 89 in Moscow we saw the
results in 19 1991 we saw the referendum
of 93 where people voted to continue the
reform against the leftist populist
Supreme Soviet and of course in December
93 again contrary to the Gerry norske
stereotype when you count the deputies
elected both on the party list and on
the single mandate list it was the again
sort of the cadets party 90 years later
it was he worth guitars Russia's choice
so so how would what should we make out
of all of this especially given what's
happening now welding first of all as
far as the you know opinion polls in
Putin's so-called high support goes I
think it's completely meaningless to
talk about opinion polls in a system
where every single major television
channel is controlled by the state
propaganda where we have now dozens of
political prisoners well we have not
mass but targeted with very cute
political repressions where we don't
have free elections you know when you
when you sit at your house and you get a
phone call and some person on the other
line asks you do you support Putin you
know I think most people will just say
yes to be on the safe side and put the
phone down so I think it's friendly
meaning let's talk about these so-called
84% that you know people talk about but
on your deeper question on the
stereotype yeah there is this very
popular myth this urban legend you know
that Russians are somehow uniquely among
other Eastern European nations unsuited
for democracy you know I think it's a
borderline racist argument frankly and
it's certainly not borne out by the
facts you mentioned the 1906 election
when indeed the the cadets won a
plurality of seats and supporters of
absolute monarchy did not win a single
seat in a state duma not one right also
we could mention the 1917 election to
the Constituent Assembly which was held
after the Bolsheviks already seized
power in a coup d'etat but the people
rejected them in the favor of the SRS
approach the pro-democracy center-left
party and of course 91 when Boris
Yeltsin the Democratic opposition
candidate beat the official Soviet
establishments candidate Nicola Irish
coffe by 57% to 17 a whopping landslide
so the you know the simple fact is that
we are no better and no worse than other
Eastern European nations including
Slovak including Orthodox Christian
nations who once lived under
totalitarian dictatorships and now have
functioning democracies and there will
come a day when Russia too will have a
functioning democracy and I think what's
important to note is that this myth that
Russians are somehow unsuited for
democracy not ready for democracy and
all the rest of it it's it's being
implicitly used by the Kremlin's
propaganda machine to imply that any
alternative to Putin would be worse or
after after Putin it will be worse
precisely so I think it's it's it's
crucial that informed and well-meaning
people do not fall for this propaganda
ruse well mo did we we're doing so well
and and your your answers are so so
excellent and concise that we have quite
a bit of time to take questions from the
floor thank you very much for located me
please questions for Vladimir Carr
Marissa please wait for the microphone
then please introduce yourself
I'm John Gizzi political correspondent
for News Max and it's such an honor to
meet you sir having heard so much about
you from our friend Elena servitors and
glad to be in your presence the
Magnitsky sanctions have been applied to
so many people and as Russia for example
continues to be a presence in Ukraine
and spreads its influence other in other
countries internationally people say why
not impose sanctions on Putin the White
House at the regular press briefings
have never ruled that out to sanction
him personally what do you think of that
and would that have an effect on him one
member said support sanctions on him
enough so that the Kremlin itself might
overthrow him thank you very much for
the question John to me in person too
and you said that there have been many
people sanctioned under the Magnitsky
law there have been quite a few but as I
mentioned earlier there are all
low-level operatives not a single
high-profile influential person in
Putin's circle has been targeted and I
think that was the intention of the law
again the the double standard of the
heart of this regime is that there
weren't a rule you know like an
oppressive cell the world dictatorship
inside of Russia but they want to enjoy
all the benefits that the free world can
offer including the financial benefits
it has to stop and as I alluded to
earlier that this idea is shared by a
lot of people in Russia that this has to
stop
there have been some high-profile cases
outside of the Magnitsky process give
just one example last year we had a
lesson who was then head of gas premedia
which is the largest state propaganda
television outlet owns NTV and other
entities he had an investigation started
against him by the FBI under the anti
money laundering and
corrupt practices act because he was he
was found out that he purchased some
luxury real estate in California and and
the purpose of investigations to find
out how how you know he was a state
official and he had to resign two days
afterwards he resigned last December
he's not in that position anymore that's
just one example of how effective this
process can be if it's applied properly
if it's done against the right people so
I think yes it would be very important
I think symbolically to sanction Putin
personally as well as ahead of this
regime but even more effective to do it
around it to do it against those people
those state connected oligarchs around
him that all of them have spare eardrums
as they'll call on right very basis
prepared in Western countries and I
think that would be really effective to
go after them and again it soon as the
third anniversary of the of the passage
and signing of the Magnitsky law and I
really hope that the administration
steps up the implementation and also
that the European Union follow suit in
all our meetings with our counterparts
in the EU times of the European
Parliament and so forth we always raise
this issue but it's really important to
do they have started to do some
sanctions targeted sanctions with
relation to the aggression on Ukraine
and actually some propagandists have
been targeted like pinchy Kiselyov
probably the most infamous one the the
one who wanted to turn the universe
radioactive ash exactly in the heap of
radius I see right the host of the most
popular television show exactly oh well
again we can talk about popular or not
but it's it's basically that when no one
when you have one dish in restaurant you
can say it's the most popular dish but
and it would be true technically but
also I think it's it's it's a very
important point to make this shouldn't
be sanctions against Russia and they
shouldn't be cold as such this should be
targeted sanctions against against those
abusers who engage in both internal
repression and external aggression and
sometimes many to many Western leaders
are careless with the language and they
do call them sanctions on Russia and
other thing that helps because that is
used by the propaganda machine to say
all over there against you know Russian
people and all the rest of it so I think
as you step up the implementation of it
it's important to be very careful about
the wording and
the presentation frankly as well please
think of more questions I mean while you
know abuse my host prerogative ask you
one let's delve a little bit deeper well
again you know putting back your expert
hat what's I mean you talked a little
bit about Syria but I mean it seems that
Ukraine I mean frozen conflict I mean my
formula is that the tie goes to Ukraine
a frozen a frozen conflict I'm not sure
this is not a positive is not transistor
this is said you know to say that that I
essentially tried and failed it is
something that the this regime I don't
think can can afford again is missed
right yeah the sense is that it's it's
not frozen its or say it's frozen but
putting controls they access to a
microwave you can you can always pop it
back in so so what do you think what
what what what what is the endgame in
Ukraine or we just go you know day by
day well he can pop it back in but if
you look at what's happening at the
moment they are backing away clearly I
mean the novorossiya project has failed
a long time ago but now even you know if
you look on state news programs on
russian state TV they for instance have
started again calling them lugansk and
donetsk regions as opposed to republics
and they've they've cancelled those you
know so-called elections that was
supposed to take place in in in right in
eastern areas this month so they're
clearly backing away and this picture
from ukraine it's not a winning picture
for them anymore it's become a quagmire
it's been a year and a half and they
failed to get you know all of the
eastern part of ukraine s as was
apparently that you know the original
plan they I hope will fail to prevent
the success of the democratic
institutions in Ukraine which is again
was a main motivation yeah and and if
you look at you know state TV again the
Ukrainians being gradually but
completely replaced with Syria wall
you're here now about Syria Syria Syria
you don't almost don't hear about
Ukraine words for the last year if you
looked on state TV you would hear
anything about Russia for instance
all you hear about is about the
Ukrainian fascists hunter you know in
Kiev and that's all changed in the last
few weeks
just just one call for clarification or
perhaps maybe projection
I think fella D you were absolutely
right to say that that the the you know
as michail Dmitrievich le told me you
know leading Russian political
sociologist long before Crimea mm-hmm
foreign policy is the only thing that's
working to this regime so so but then
okay so Ukraine now is being slowly
abandoned
now there's Syria but but if this logic
is you know Dmitry is logic and I what I
understand is yo logic holds then the
there will have to be something after
Syria I mean that this patriotic
mobilization has to be I mean he he he
settled the tiger and the Tigers trot
trotting rather successfully but you got
a feed tiger with with meat and the
bloodier the better so what what what's
the projection there I think the thing
with those is that at some point it will
simply stop working you know if you look
at our history small victorious Wars
never ended well for the you know for
our dictatorships beginning with a of
course the russo-japanese war the one
that term was invented for when the
phrase yeah play right right right play
exactly and then you know Afghanistan
again that we mentioned that helped
hasten the demise of the Soviet regime
and even if you look at the first world
war for instance you know the the
patriotic the pro monarchist hype that
accompanied the beginning of it and look
what happened just three years later so
I don't think we can take it or we
should take it for granted that this
will continue to work for them and they
will just go to next target the next
target if Syria becomes for Putin what
Afghanistan became for the Soviet
Politburo then you know this is the last
military adventure he's entered and it
quite possibly one of the last few
things big things his regime has engaged
himself sir Anderson
and the trolls lumpy Atlantic Council
three questions if I may first on that
Magnitsky act we know that the
government the White House is very happy
to sanction people but you know
according to that midweek ski act
because the Magnitsky Act means that the
Congress has a say over it and the
administration prefers to have it all in
its own hands shouldn't you focus on
being sanctions instead given that the
White House is so much more happy to do
that than under the Magnitsky Act isn't
shouldn't the Magnitsky act for
practical reasons they put on a back
burner because all white houses have
been burned by the jackson-vanik Act but
I couldn't get rid for 20 years when it
was no longer applicable second question
what do you make of the demise of
Vladimir Coonan the head of the Russian
railroads considered one of the ten top
people around
Booton as a good KGB general from
saint-petersburg and then he just
disappears like this so you would be
interesting if you elaborate upon it and
from what you talked before about it
would be interesting to see to hear how
do you think that this regime can fall
who died coughs gets told us very firmly
but he thinks that this can not fall
through elections and how do you see
about this regime could fall alternative
scenarios and probabilities thank you
thank you very much Chancellor Anderson
it's great to see you and I'll start
with your last question if I may
of course it's not going to change
through elections we don't have real
elections as you know and know we we
happen to believe that our countries had
enough revolutions to the last century
and we wouldn't like to see another one
certainly not another bloody one but
what this regime does they're doing
really the best they can to make sure
that when the the power does change as
it never
we'll nothing is permanent it will do so
not on a constitutional not on a
peaceful way you know they have this new
Pro Kremlin movement called ante Maidan
right presumably it's you know against
revolutions and they and they accuse us
the Russian opposition of wanting amide
are launching a revolution in fact I
think the biggest supporters and the
biggest instigators of the Russian of a
future Russian Maidan are sitting in the
Kremlin right now because when you shut
off every single legal Avenue to protest
expressing alternative opinion when you
have no free elections you have no
independent media on a big scale so
certainly on television when you have no
working judicial system you're ensuring
that when society does or the active
part of society does have enough of of
these people as again as it will
inevitably and I think sooner rather
than later it's not going to be peaceful
it's not gonna be constitutional and I'm
saying it I'm not happy about it I'm
saying this you know was sorrow that's I
don't think that's gonna be good for
anybody but that's what that's right
that's what they're making sure about
everything they do so yeah I don't think
I don't see how the regime can change
through elections since we don't have
free elections now when you questioned
by the Magnitsky Act sure they can act I
mean the as you know the executive here
has the authority to sanction anybody
anyway it's it's it's the right of the
u.s. to give or not to give somebody a
visa so they can they can just do it
anytime they wish of course the the
reason the Magnitsky Act was passed was
because they didn't do it that they
didn't use that authority and I think
it's also important that the Magnitsky
Act provides a concrete motivation it's
the human rights abuse it's the
corruption the graft it's you know there
are all these executive actions as you
know there is the President Obama's
executive order about Ukraine there are
sanctions applied to those involved in
aggression against Ukraine and they are
acting on that too but I think it's
important to have the human rights
motivation because as we know from the
founding documents of the OSCE which
bound both Russia and the United States
human rights are not an internal affair
whatever mr. Putin mr. Lavrov continue
to say the Moscow document of the OSCE
clearly states the issues of human
rights and fundamental
could not be considered internal affair
of a member state so human rights
concerns everybody and I think that's
why it's such an important symbolic act
and after all the majorities were huge
and bipartisan and the President signed
it so I think they should really abide
by you know a United States federal law
but of course you're right they can do
it otherwise as well and if they for
some reason decided just to sanction
people outside of the law you know I
wouldn't see any problem with that but
of course I think will be more effective
it's and if it's under the process and
you couldn't there's a new version out
about you codons sacking I'm sure you
saw it yesterday it's when his son
applied for a British British passport
and that was considered a sign of
unloyal fear I guess in the Kremlin or
something but a lot of people are saying
that this is the beginning of the fight
under the carpet already
and these Kremlin clans that are
beginning to clash with each other and
and as you know as the crisis deepens
the crisis of the regime deepens I think
we'll see more and more of this there
won't be any friends left in the in the
car parity for Zara as it were and I
think he may be the first sign of that
and you're right he just went nowhere
first he was supposed to be given a
conciliatory position of a senator of
course which is a rubber-stamp position
in russia it's not like Saturday here
but even that he he rejected as you know
he's probably considered too too modest
an offer frankly and you're right he's
just gone completely nowhere one of the
closest people to Putin and I think
there'll be others to follow
if we remember again the big protests in
the end of 2011 we saw what many
considered what was the beginning of the
split of the elites back then when we
saw you know Kudrin on soccer of avenue
proper of Mahlon so coughs of something
remember of course that these are the
best people in the country right so and
that was unfortunate that was too short
a time and then that the regime regained
the initiative and and and and it's been
doing what has been doing since you know
suppressing and repressing but once that
moment starts again and I'm I've no
doubt it will I think we'll see some
more interesting dynamic at the top
there Laura please and identify yourself
where's our microphone no no Joe right
here
I'm ready now it's so nice to see you
I'm from the Figaro I have a question
about Europe the you have described the
the powerful you know influence of the
propaganda machine in inside Russia what
about the property Russian propaganda
war in Europe it is being waged daily as
we see and with quite a lot of success
actually the we've seen you know
increasing support for putting
throughout Europe especially countries
like France you know where you have
whole political parties on the extreme
right but also people on the Left and
many leaders in the in the Gollust party
supporting now some kind of alliance
compromise with Putin and it's only
going to increase with these migrants
crisis and Putin seems to have made
clear to the Europeans at some point
maybe they're gonna have to give up you
know on sanctions maybe on Ukraine if
they want this Syrian you know mass to
stopped otherwise he could he could
actually mess it up even more so how do
you think this is gonna play out I mean
are you worried about this this kind of
divide of Europe that Putin seems to be
seeking pretty successfully sure thanks
for the question is an important one and
of course well the Kremlin is you know
writing against so-called fascist in
Ukraine it's pretty happy to make
friends with the far-right in the
European Union countries like you
mentioned a phony scenario so the
Hungarian far-right and there was
recently a big conference of the
far-right parties from across Europe in
st. Petersburg it was actually held in
the same hotel and in the same hall
where we open Russia was supposed to
host a forum in December and it was of
course broken up by police but were the
fashions they have no problem that's
fine
he's you're right he is that Putin is in
the Kremlin is aggressive in trying to
split the EU get it his support and he
you ratchet up the propaganda in URT and
you know other other means I think it's
important first of all to recognize it
that this is happening because not
everybody does some people like to close
their eyes tonight shopping here as well
but to a lesser extent much more so in
the European Union so I think it's
important to recognize it and to
recognize that it's not you know a good
thing to do and actually to again the
origins of everything are domestic and
that's why I think it was such a good
proposition by the European Union
presidency which was held by Latvia then
last year to create a new Russian
language pan European television channel
which would also be broadcasting to
Russia itself I think that's a really
important notion because you have to
combat the the roots of this propaganda
at the heart of it where it's
originating from but of course also it's
going to be easier for EU countries to
try to combat it on their own territory
so at least I think they should be doing
that and not to mix up propaganda with
free speech they're very different
things we heard from critics of the idea
for instance to include the
propagandists Putin state propagandists
into the targeted sanctions here in this
country you know and what about the
First Amendment well you know free
speech and incitement are different
things and when state employees use
state resources and state money to hound
political opponents of the regime on
national TV
you know things they said about boris
nemstov when he was alive you know that
he would have welcomed nazi troops in
moscow 1941 that he was in the pay of
the Americans that he was a traitor all
the rest of you should you know it so
you can see all the quotations this is
not free speech this is not the First
Amendment and and I think when these
arguments are being voiced in the EU
these are not correct arguments frankly
I think propaganda should be recognized
and confronted please yes
my name is James Byrne I'm a longtime
journalist circum and some might pay a
lot of attention to in recent years is
the very sad demographic reality it was
going on in Russia whoo
male life expectancy is plummeting and
that I've attended a lot of discussions
by Russian demographers and this and I'm
wondering what impact will that very bad
demographic picture have on the
government now thanks for the question
yeah I think we have one of the biggest
gaps in the world between male and
female life expectancy it's 11 or 12
years and in fact that's been a
situation since the Soviet time since
midnight early to mid-1980s if you take
Russia not the Soviet Union as a whole
Russia because of course was just again
another myth about the horrendous
so-called horrendous 1990s is that
that's one of the demographic problems
began now they began under the Soviet
system and essentially they continued
today the only region which has a you
know surplus more people born than
people are dying is the North Caucasus
are the Muslim regions of southern
Russia which is you know whole other
subject for discussion as well how is
that going to build for the future but I
think the bottom line is this regime
doesn't care about long-term national
interests of Russia be it what happens
inside our country or what happens in
relation to our foreign affairs and all
the pieces will have to pick up once
they're gone with restoring our position
in the world so that's why these
problems are continuing and exacerbating
and not getting better all they care
about is to preserve their power and
frankly you know I don't think they give
even a small thought to the Democratic
problem that you mentioned for instance
they're very happy about their opponents
leaving the country and these are you
know we have a massive brain drain
frankly in the last few years from
Russia people leaving in great numbers
educated people intellectual people
because you know they cannot stand the
atmosphere anymore I think it's a
tragedy I think you know of course it's
not my place everybody decides for their
own life but I think
the tragedy that so many such people are
leaving but they're happy about it the
regimes because you know fewer
troublemakers easier to control
who's left I still think I mean I still
think that doing there's still think
they're gonna fail but that's what
they're doing
thank you ladies and gentlemen for those
who don't know in front of you are two
of people from Russia who are probably
some of the most cultured and educated
in topics of Russian culture not just
politics and all this stuff that we are
all fond of so and this is my question
to Lady Mary Bloody Mary please after my
short comment prove me wrong please
I really want to be proven wrong so in
1825 a bunch of young noble heroic
aristocrats pretty much looking like the
America decided I guess some of you
ancestors without they hang though
decided decided that the regime was
awful unfair which it was and they all
ended up in Siberia or being hung in
1827 Pushkin wrote a poem which sounded
very much like what we heard from
Latimer new preparedness coordinate
through the semester millennia that the
prisons will collapse and the freedom
will meet you at the gate 1827 110 years
later we know Stalin's purges happened
right and on and on and on to make it
short
some twenty years ago I would say
everything buddy Merced because I was
also young I was I really wanted to
believe that this time is different
and so Vladimir is now saying this
he's in the u.s. Lyon as I said one of
the most cultural people he's in the US
I'm actually American citizen since 2005
who's there
I mean why would that happen please
prove me wrong I think everyone who has
potential is either in prison or killed
or emigrated you travel in regions when
I travel in regions twenty-something
years ago I was afraid I'll be murdered
and decapitated when they heard that I
was guided as press secretary and he was
on the stage and I thought oh my God
he's bodyguards I don't because people
we're fueling with hatred so you travel
do you see these young people maybe in
the region somebody who is ready to burn
and continue this for another I don't
know how much it takes 100 200 years
thanks for the question it's it's a
really deep on an important one and of
course your last point time goes much
quicker now
and those Decembrists you mentioned
those who are still alive as you know
we're Frieden returned in one of the
first symbolic acts of alexander ii in
1855 and they did returned us in
petersburg they were old but there was a
symbolic move but time goes faster now I
don't think it's going to take another
30 years but that's certainly not
another 74 years and I think Vladimir
Bukovsky made this core point a comment
once and I think it's it's it says it's
right to the point that he says what
always surprises me in a good way is
that however much repression there is
and however strong the dictatorship is
you know however many people leave or I
imprison or are killed they always
remain people in Russia who have who our
Appiah in minded who want a normal
future based in rule of law on democracy
on respect for the dignity of a human
being there are always such people and
as I travel around the country I see
them I see them especially among the
young generation I wouldn't say it's
it's the majority of the young
generation because the young generation
has really been I think the main victim
of this horrible propaganda campaign
that
unleashing over the past 10-15 years but
but there are many of them and they are
there and our job for instance that you
know the main tasks of the open Russian
movement is try to support and
consolidate those people who want a
European future for our country and
Bukowski's right always at every
generation there are enough people and
we remember as you alluded to you know
in 91 when the the poachers had
everything they had the whole state
apparatus they had that all all the
television channels by the way they had
the Communist Party they had the KGB
what are the most feared organization in
the history of the world but when two
hundred thousand people came out and
stood in front of the tanks and refused
to leave they failed the purchased I
mean the coup leaders failed and I think
frankly that's that's the destiny of all
of those who want to drag our country
back to the Middle Ages back to
suppression under different guises in
forms it may take some time the price
may be high it's already really high we
already lost so many people and we lost
you know we lost were lost Boris this
year and these last few months have been
really really dark but there was a you
know famous saying that Soviet
dissidents like to say the night is
darkest before the dawn and I believe
that I still believe that freedom and
justice will prevail in the end in
Russia and you said I'm in the u.s. I'm
you know I'm recuperating in the US
after what happened but once I recover
further I will go back and I will resume
my work as coordinator of open Russia
because as we discussed this is our job
no one is going to do it for us and I
believe that freedom and justice will
prevail and I think we have to do
everything we can to bring that day a
little bit closer ah please right there
yes I'm Russell King retired federal
employee I have a question about Putin's
Nate Naval intentions when Putin took
over Sevastopol I can't help thinking he
must have had naval intentions because
that's where the Black Sea Fleet is
based and as I understand it I believe
that Ukraine had a lease lease that base
to Russian there might have been a limit
on the number of ships and and once
Russia took over I think maybe that
limit disappears and the terms of
transit going through the Turkish
straits are much much better for Russia
than for the United States because I
believe it's governed by the Montreux
convention of the mid 1930s and and it
gives preferential transit privileges to
black sea nations which would include
Russia what it would include include
Ukraine but I don't believe it it it
accounts for the fact that you might
have an active war of one Black Sea
nation against another and and III would
think that the Black Sea Fleet would
supply Syria and I believe that the port
there might be TARDIS and in the Arctic
the United States and NATO has none of
its own icebreakers I think we're
totally dependent upon Norwegian and
Danish
icebreakers in the NATO area but with
the Russian Northern Fleet there they're
very active in the northern sea route I
believe is now functioning for for local
shipping and may in a few years possibly
even be an international sea realm in
which case I think it would be the
shortest distance between Europe North
America and in East Asia and also there
due to the the warming there there are
some resource grabs in international
waters in the Arctic so I'm wondering
can you tell me a little bit about the
Russian naval intentions and what what
the US response would should likely be
sure thanks it's an interesting question
I'm not a naval expert although my
father-in-law as a naval officer
probably should be but I would say that
we already saw
well this Syria operation going on now
we saw some strikes from the Caspian Sea
two days ago and there actually are some
questions raised as to whether or not
these were medium-range missiles that
would violate the 1987
treaty between the u.s. well you were
actually effectively abrogated a treaty
right so it's button sand and happy I'll
show it right but I think again that the
everything that happened with Crimea for
instance he wasn't primarily about you
know gaining the fleet we had the fleet
there anyway as you say it was until
2017 was the current agreement but we
probably would have been prolonged but I
think he had domestic mainly propaganda
objectives and it worked for the regime
for about a year I guess it's it's worn
off now the effect but it's it worked
for about a year that's hype so I don't
think my main point is I don't think
what they do is primarily directed to
foreign policy and strategic goals again
it's the preservation of their power
inside the country they'll need military
adventures and they think that will help
them they will do it as we as we saw
with Ukraine as we see with Syria I'm
sure they'll be happy to use naval
resources too and of course you said
that the limits on the Black Sea Fleet
are gone well everything that happens in
Crimea now is technically illegal since
the annexation nothing is according to
convention and law anymore so sure it
could be it could be done anything could
be done but again I think we have to
look for domestic motivations domestic
factors and the answers to the problems
are also domestic over there somebody
was very patient thank you very much
thank you my name is Katie Fox I'm from
the National Democratic Institute it's
also very nice to see you and to see you
in good health I hope I have a couple of
questions about the organized opposition
to Putin or what might potentially
succeed him my two questions are how
strong is the alternative to Putin on
the far right the sort of nationalist
leaders how likely are they to succeed
him and my other question is can you
address another myth about Russia which
is that the more liberal democratic
opposition of which you are part tends
to shoot itself in the foot by internal
infighting and
elitism and disorganization alright
thanks a lot for the questions Kay's
good to see you well I think it's it's a
it's an accepted truth that you know
fascists are generally more organized
and liberals so to your last point I
think is a problem and what we had open
Russia tried to do an open Russia is not
a party it's an umbrella movement
organization tries to consolidate and
when I work with people in the regions
these are people from own you know fara
just only from Parnassus people is also
people from yeah blocker from other
smaller parties without any party
affiliation is a big part of people who
work with so we're trying to at least
try to remedy that a little bit and we
have seen in recent years some hopeful
moves on consolidation we've seen as new
Democratic coalition for instance being
created this spring which was of course
barred from the ballot in most places it
was supposed to run as I mentioned
earlier but you know I'm hoping that I
wish this less than what has been
learned sooner you know I think 2003 was
a decisive year when if it's both in ya
block I've had been together in one
block the whole history of Russia would
have been different after that but we
have what we have but we're trying to
learn I'm you know I'm with you on this
I think it doesn't make any sense that
we're not consolidated and I personally
and my colleagues I know will do
everything we can to try to achieve it
but of course at the critical points I
think we are like in in the protests in
2011-2012 everybody was on below
everybody was on Sahara those people
from yeah Baraka for para nós from other
parties from no parties at all actually
most most people were not from any
parties at all so I think I still hope
we're gonna get there and then in terms
of nationalists the Kremlin has done a
lot to you know to nurture and to grow
up this nationalist itself for instance
with what has been doing in Ukraine
these guys are now coming back so called
novorossiya volunteers and they the
Kremlin is gonna soon find a thing that
they're not actually very much
supporters of it as many people
originally told them when they started
doing it but they have been toying with
the Nationalists
abroad you know I mention this European
fascists conference that was held in San
Peter
work he's been talking with nationalisms
inside you know one of the nationalist
firebrands Rogozin was a number of
Putin's government was appointed in 2012
so the colonel has been toying at
thinking it could control it because the
problem with all these movements is they
often go out of control and and they're
in I think lies a danger not just for
this regime but for our country as a
whole but I still I still not just
believe but I know from from my
experience with you know dealing with a
lot of people including outside of
Moscow st. Petersburg that you know this
far right
they don't have genuine strong
popularity they do not and when for
instance you know the the big protest
movement of 2011 2012 it was unified
right it included everybody including
nationalists but when the Levada Center
did a big survey of bulletin and suhara
we found that the Nationalists accounted
for 6% just 6% of the of the unified
protesters so I think it's hyped up 2 or
2 more than what it actually is but I
also think there is there is a danger
but that danger is coming from the top
not from the bottom so it's not genuine
support that these far-right forces have
in Russian side I don't think they have
but it's the fact that the Kremlin
opportunistically toys with them and
that could be a potential source of
problem there's one in the back now
there oh yes somebody in the back please
Thank You Emma Louise Leahy from
Denton's and I had two questions about
Russia's relationships in the Middle
East one is after the nuclear deal and
with Russia and Iran both supporting the
Assad regime in Syria what do you see is
the future of the Russian Iranian
relationship and the other to what
extent is Putin concerned about losing
standing in the Sunni world as a result
of his support for Assad thank you and
absolutely this was one of the questions
I could pick it back also add to this
Europe you know your second one is
extremely important you know there are
foreign ministry estimates that there
are 2,400
fighters from Russia itself in in among
Isis and and up to five thousand of
Russian speakers and that of course
includes Central Asia way up to this the
fact that the most recruitment occurs in
Moscow and and in Russia rather than
Uzbekistan Tajikistan and Kyrgyzstan and
the fact that that eventually one way or
another does in fact Putin alluded to
that in his speech at the UN that that
that they tasted blood they'll be coming
back this I think this this could be an
issue of enormous importance so if you
could you know address that you know
first of all Iran just to recap you know
Russia's goal in the Middle East and and
then finally this issue of of Sunnis
that that Putin is frankly desperately
afraid of because because of the Central
Asia connection and because those
regimes once Taliban is undermined
successfully which i think is an only a
matter of time of Afghanistan Central
Asia will begin to fall and given the
the fact that there are about five
million migrant workers only legally
registered in Russia from Central Asia
it could be an enormous problem for the
regime absolutely and I think and thanks
for the question I think that's a
classic case of where I know that the
Syria adventure is a classic case of
where the regime is trying to preserve
its own power at the expense of
long-term interests of our country this
is not the only well you know place
they're doing it but that's certainly I
think one of the most visible ones of
course the majority of Russian Muslims
are Sunnis right and we've already seen
Saudi Sunni clerics declaring jihad
against Russia earlier this week as a
result of intervention in Syria there is
talk of you know potential consequences
frankly with regard to terrorism in
Russia itself with regard to events in
the North Caucasus which has been
volatile anyway and none of this bodes
well for our country and for a long-term
national interest and again that's that
I think that's one of the most classic
cases where they choose their own
self-preservation or short term
even as well at that you know the
propaganda effect that is going to give
them for a few months against at the
expense of the long-term interests of
Russia in terms of our position in the
Middle East this regime is continuing
with you know essentially what the
Soviet foreign policy was in the Middle
East with the exception that we still
have diplomatic relations with Israel
the Soviet Union did not but you know
again usually we always we it's a bad
week the chroman regime gives Israel a
cold shoulder usually and it's trying to
be friendly with the regime in Tehran we
saw general Soleimani come to Moscow few
weeks before the beginning of the
operation Syria I think it's very
possible that they were discussing it as
well and of course now we're officially
in a coalition with the regime in Tehran
just as we are with again we the Kremlin
regime with will the regime of Assad and
and and so on so I think this is the
model there continuing with I don't
think it's the right one frankly I mean
I'm of course evidently I'm one of those
who believes that our natural alliances
lie in the Western world you know Russia
is a European nation
naturalize allies are our neighbors in
Europe and if we talk about the Middle
East it should be the only genuine
democracy in the Middle East which is
Israel and I think a future Russian
government that is democratic will be
doing that just as we begin to do it in
1990s for a brief time but for now we
have to unfortunately state that that's
the foreign policy and that's the
Alliance policy of the of this regime
Iran Assad and this club of dictators
that were mentioned earlier oh yeah just
wanted to thank you again and I think I
speak for everybody in this in this
whole in this audience that we just in
admiration of your personal heroism and
the heroic work you're doing in Russia
thank you thank you so much
you